the idea is something close we can track
an answer for a long time he was just
down there at president's circle and
they were handing out sharp objects to
stab people with so they had someone
coming with an 8k why did it take to
late night hosts comedians to find this
out I you know what I wish you guys like
Marley was dead to begin with okay there
you go verifiable proof that an tyfa is
premeditatedly and proactively violent
and you'll see more in this video then
you've probably ever seen before the
kinds of attacks they plot how they
coordinate what tools they use even more
importantly you'll see a complicit media
who one offered this very footage turned
the other way how do we know all this
because we've been infiltrating this
organization for a long time hard but
first you'll need a primer protests
violence Riots calling everyone a Nazi
this is the mo of antiphon we've all
seen it but the media politicians in
academia all defend deflect or
completely deny they are strictly
principled anti-fascist what we saw with
some brave people risking their lives
that group protests fascism maybe their
tactics weren't exactly right it's messy
and so far our people who go and they
try to push back on these guys but it is
not the tape that they are going around
building an armed movement fascism
cannot be defeated through speech you
need to take it with the utmost
seriousness before it's too late
black lives matter the Antipa movement
is interested in preserving the fabric
of America an tyfa is one of those
things that somebody came up with as a
catchphrase so that you could say you
know oh there are violence on the other
side why is that why defend the
indefensible are they really just an
inconsequential group of rabble rousers
how deep does an tifa's organization go
what's their end game well for several
months we tracked and infiltrated an
tyfa culminating in their violent
protest of the notorious jewish Nazi
speaker ben shapiro at the university of
utah but before we get to the part where
we send not gay jared in undercover
vulnerable afraid and shaking like a
Chinese Crested without one of those
little gaze sweaters a little backstory
I want to kick my own ass in order to
get in with the aunt of a crowd we had
to infiltrate their private groups after
news broke that they were officially
classified as a domestic terrorist
organization they pulled everything in
much closer to the chest
they started vetting people becoming
paranoid about spies the demand did we
meet with them in person installing a
cryptic messaging app on to our phone
which they used to organize so just met
with the guy and he installed a super
secret to encrypt and messenger app on
my phone and they immediately took roll
call using all pseudonyms such as fire
bird ski mask devious xavius yeah
everyone except for will yes will when
we immediately identified on Facebook
will also boasted of his sawed-off
shotguns and armory in his trunk at
least that's what he said
I have like on the border between just
regular right now
startups ouch
yeah I drew with the deck
so remember just as the local
authorities will remember this is well
what happened to you will somewhere on
the way you lost yourself believe me it
gets worse the context makes all of us
so much worse
Oh also yes the violent antfee organizer
is seemingly a [ __ ] and or genderqueer
patients now to be fair anyone can
likely show up in protest but they told
us that all of this was required if we
wanted to take part in their
self-professed
tactics now just what do they mean by
tactics but we found out the next day
again patients first to understand what
their tactics are understand that an
tyfa is now in a PR battle so what they
claim and what they do are two very
different things
despite wanting to put distance between
themselves in anti fun despite what
resident gauge and sjw in chief george
takei tweets out an tyfa has never
operated alone they've been actively
supported by professors and other
leftists and student organizations for
example current University of Utah
faculty like Cindy Geralyn Salomon
clappa and a Linda McKenna encouraged
and emboldened students to disrupt a Ben
Shapiro event to create chaos people
like ben shapiro are the most dangerous
people on this earth and we're gonna
fight him tomorrow are we solidarity in
student organizations like the students
for a Democratic Society because that's
the thing not only work alongside
antiphon when convenient but work with
them to scope out police and even to
provide pseudo security by committing
acts of violence
auntie fuzz just to be clear it's not an
organization that's what we want to know
it's short for a anti-fascist and I'm
absolutely anti-fascist and I would echo
what Ian just said anti-fur as a label
does not mean a one static organization
but it's definitely an ideology a
movement a stance if you may of
anti-fascism bar none we signs
explicitly ask these people who show up
in black bloc to show up these Antipa
people to show up because you know in
the past we've been threatened by 3% us
we've been threatened by neo-nazis
who've been threatened by these people
before and their presence gives people
in immense more amount of safety now
according to an toughies own words what
makes them different the difference
between them and many of the other
activist groups is the willingness to
respond with violence see the ultimate
problem with antiphon the organizations
and professors who support them is that
because they paint their opposition as
nazis they've developed their very own
unique code as to what warrants a
violent response they are ready and
looking for
order between just regular rifle
startup style but I've got I've got a
the willingness to respond with violence
the way that I would address what you
were just asking about it I I would I
don't want to disavow an ally within the
movement the no pictures no pictures
that part I would say it's
understandable given what I was just
talking about with anonymity
now context don't forget what you got to
do can include violence against anyone
you call a Nazi they call ben shapiro a
nazi they're allowed to commit violence
against anyone filming them in just how
violent can they get combat knife it's
explained five inches or so it's just
you strap it on your leg
this was like tiny so you have to really
stabbing them yeah whoa whoa hold luring
people to their cars with sawed-off
shotguns and handing out knives and
SHIVs
this went far beyond a goof and we
needed to get knock a jarrett out of
there good thing the man's got a quick
mind
sorry place to [ __ ] around here I don't
lose campus he has gonna be in a few
minutes yes the risk of being called a
snitch not gay Jerrod immediately turned
the footage over to the authorities who
were already aware of our presence there
by the way turns out they've been
tracking this pansexual slash
transgender queer with an axe to grind
for a while and they were grateful for
our footage the media on the other hand
who you think would jump on a story like
this well their response is what's most
disturbing of all he was just down there
at president circle and they were
handing out sharp objects to stab people
with so they had someone coming with a
take a why did it take - late night
hosts comedians to find this out yes you
just saw correctly even being shown the
footage in the presence of police
officers to confirm authenticity they
walked away also I should note this is
Dan Harris from Nightline national ABC
News he knew about the footage in the
whole story - I offered it to him and
asked for his card he did not give it to
me we were delivering a story to local
and national news on a silver platter
which included infiltration violence and
exposing the roots of a national
domestic terrorist organization and no
one even wanted to give it a glimpse not
one person it didn't even get mentioned
protesters flooding the campus trying to
shut down conservative Speaker Ben
Shapiro's appearance these are
protesters that are against - Ben
Shapiro conservative only these people
didn't call Ben Shapiro controversial
they called him a Nazi and they aren't
there to protest they are there to punch
Nazis as they chalk and paint on the
walls or commit violence against people
filming them depending on the day
case in point our footage assisted with
leading to the arrests of these violent
protesters good example codenamed
honeybee her real name is Jenna now let
me be clear here we do not want to Doc's
anyone and we ask that none of you Doc's
anyone but we do want
you to alert your local authorities if
you recognize any of these people these
folks aren't playing a game anymore
this is serious violence take this black
girl who committed assault now we
couldn't find any official arrest record
but we did post this on Facebook and
then this happened so we immediately
ID'd her as well graceful they're so
easy to trick officers we appreciate
your service now of course the next day
when the inevitable violence that we
warned about broke out so-called
journalists were all over it because you
know they're lazy here's the thing
antiphon and its supporters are openly
practicing violence worse they plan it
they plan to escalate it as you can see
now if they call ben shapiro or me and
not see what does that make you if they
justify violence against someone with I
don't know an iPhone camera what can
they do to you but worst of all why did
it take a late-night podcast host and
its producer to do this kind of
journalism cryptic messaging apps
private groups handing out illegal
weapons and planning tactics do you mean
to tell me that no one at ABC NBC CBS
CNN with billions of dollars and
resources could have done this
it took steven crowder and not gay
Jarrod to pull off with some plane
tickets and a couple burner phones sure
listen
Anka feels violent they suck we get it
very violent but the fact the media has
never reported on any of this begs the
question are they complicit is the media
complicit with all of this or do they
just suck at their jobs
I know who you are under file and I know
what you want if you're looking for a
safe space I can tell you because I have
no sympathy what I can tell you is that
I have a very particular set of skills
skills that I've acquired over a very
long period of time skills that make me
a nightmare for people like you if you
stop your acts of violence now that'll
be the end of it I will not look for you
I will not pursue you but if you don't I
will look for you I will find you and I
will I do
[Music]